Easter eggs are fun right you're goddamn
right I mean that's why I made a video
on them and you guys really seem to dig
that one however a lot has happened
since I uploaded that video and even
more Easter eggs callbacks references or
whatever you want to call them have come
to my attention thanks to the always
happy and not at all toxic comment
section of YouTube now isn't that right
comment section fantastic
so because I love you here are 10 more
Dragon Ball super Easter eggs I found
thanks in no small part to you guys and
where better to begin a list created by
the fans than with a reference to a fan
made parody number 10 longtime fans of
the Dragon Ball series are no stranger
to the happy loyal and well borderline
racially insensitive attendant to the
guardian of Earth mister Popo however
over the last decade a certain group of
fans has come together to create
something truly special
a beloved Dragon Ball parody that has
garnered hundreds of millions of views
across YouTube alone ok I am of course
referring to Dragon Ball Z abridged it's
because of this fan productions
widespread popularity I have decided to
consider this an easter egg
and so in episode 91 of Dragon Ball
super as Vegeta is making his way into
the hyperbolic time chamber he is
reprimanded by mr. Popo who is framed
like this to anyone who has seen Dragon
Ball Z abridged you know exactly what
this is in reference to
number 9 Co enma is the son of an Matteo
and these fine folk are characters from
YuYu Hakusho in my last video I touched
on the possibility of the pacifier in
Vegeta's mouth during the Fatah park
being a reference to baby from Dragon
Ball GT however fans were quick to point
out to me that the effects of that
pacifier were similar to one Co enmons
pacifier and sorry if I'm butchering the
names here I I haven't seen you you
Hakusho I probably should the pacifier
gathers his pure Reiki and can be used
as a powerful seal so not only was this
visually similar it happened to have a
lot of the same properties also so thank
you comments section for that one number
8 moving swiftly on from an earlier
scene to a more recent one episode 125
saw a familiar Galactic Emperor return
in a rather familiar way leading up to
the climax of Dragon Ball Z's frieza
saga to the surprise of Goku piccolo go
on and
that Krillin Frieza had made a
miraculous return white after Goku had
landed what many of us considered the
final blow fast forward just hundreds
and hundreds of episodes at this point
and you'll eventually find a scene where
Frieza is being pummeled to oblivion by
topo a representative of universe 11
with Frieza having been decimated many
of us watching thought he was down for
the count for sure however just as topo
is about to deal the final blow to
Android 17 out pops Frieza assuming a
pose identical to that of his return
during the frieza saga of Z number 7 no
K this is a fun one and to be completely
honest it went completely over my head
when I watched the series the first time
how many of you have seen Back to the
Future a great movie right super fun
memorable and not to mention influential
and if you haven't seen it I'm sure you
at least know about The Time Machine
it's famous for as well as the specific
part that allows it to function within
the story the flux capacitor capacitor
which is what makes time travel possible
so what if I told you that the time
machine wasn't the only thing dragon
ball and back to the future had in
common what if I told you that bulma two
implemented a certain part in her time
machine
looks sort of familiar doesn't it that's
a damn flux capacitor if I ever saw one
needless to say I thought this was a
nice touch and a wonderful reference to
an even more wonderful movie if you
haven't seen it I couldn't recommend it
more number six the episode is Dragon
Ball super 119 the situation find and
eliminate those pesky invisible enemies
so the fighters of universe 7 are tasked
with finding a strategy to deal with
these unprecedented foes you might
remember Master Roshi advises Gohan to
induce a nosebleed thus covering these
invisible foes in his own blood first of
all gross but one might have thought
this is being a throwaway goofy Master
Roshi line right well it is but it also
has its roots set deep in Dragon Balls
history specifically this is a callback
to the fortune-teller Baba saga of
Dragon Ball when Master Roshi after
coming into contact with her breasts
proceeds to nosebleed all over the
invisible men allowing young chat to see
him clearly crazy how Master Roshi's
mind works sometimes that's what I call
it team player number 5 man another
pitaka walk Easter Egg huh this better
be good yeah well this is good so [ __ ]
you or at least I thought it was so how
many of you out there have heard of the
meme it's over 9000
oh what's that all of you have well it
might come as a surprise to some of you
that the now English voice of Vegeta
Christopher Sabbat was not the one to
popularize that line nope
that honor goes to Brian Drummond who
played the role of Vegeta in the ocean
dub before him for Western audiences but
what does this have to do with super you
might be asking well guess who
Funimation hired to play the role of
copy Vegeta in the pitar Park is this
what you'd like to do to me
[Music]
now that's what I call smart casting
never in my life have I tuned in
specifically to hear a voice actors
performance before and needless to say
it was awesome and nostalgic number four
all right this one is it here because of
me I personally just like this fact and
so I'll keep it brief in a new episode
of Dragon Ball super we see Android 17
and Gohan team-up funny that because on
that very same year in the Future Trunks
timeline adults future Gohan was killed
by both Android 17 and 18 and here they
are just working together ain't that
nice number three while the Dragon Ball
community's thoughts on kefla are if he
to say the least
I personally enjoyed her fight with Goku
heck the fight alone had probably like
single favorite Kombat moments in the
entire series and yes that's including
instant transmission kamehameha
however fangirling aside there was an
instance many of you might have thought
to be familiar during that fight and
that moment was this
[Applause]
[Music]
ringing any bells what if I show you
this I bet some of you out there thought
that this was the first time Goku ever
did a move like that well it's not it
was against another girl fighter from
the original run of Dragon Ball and not
just any girl
chichi in the 23rd World Martial Arts
Tournament Goku faces off against chichi
Ngoc you're out of bounds with nothing
but the sheer force from his punch those
of you in the comment section who
noticed that good going admittedly this
might be a bit of a stretch but I
couldn't watch that scene without
thinking about this scene number two all
right now this one might have been
obvious to you if you had seen the
original run of Dragon Ball back in the
day nor recently I don't know when or if
you've watched it geez or do I
the scene in question comes from episode
71 of Dragon Ball super in that episode
remember when Goku was carrying that
fish and got hit by boomers car well
that's actually how they met in the very
first episode of Dragon Ball way back in
the 80s he even had the same fish number
one and last but certainly not least we
ventured back to everyone's favorite are
comparable super the resurrection
specifically episode 16 within which we
find ourselves watching Vegeta in a very
flamboyant manner failed to prepare a
nice meal for Wiese now this might seem
like an average everyday slice of life
scene until you look closer in my last
Easter Egg video I spoke about the
Sandman and durian fruit which found
their way into Vegeta's luscious locks
they were the fruit puns which helped
craft the names our bond and dodoria
from the Nanak saga of Dragon Ball Z
take a close look at the ingredients on
the table next to Vegeta's mixing bowl
we have cream yogurt milk cheese and
butter these are believe it or not the
king you force burner is butter Jace is
cheese ghoul dough is derived from the
Japanese word yogurt though Riku is a
rearrangement of the sounds that make up
the Japanese word for cream kou rain and
ginyu is derived from the japanese word
for milk and i'm sorry if i butcher this
ginger again this was something that
completely flew over my radar and it was
really cool spotting it after the fact
as I mentioned this is the second video
I've made discussing Dragon Ball super
Easter eggs and the last ones final
entry seemed to really hit everyone
emotionally so if you haven't seen it
and would like to the link is in the
description down below as always
comments or ratings are very much
appreciated and if you'd like to see
more Dragon Ball super craziness feel
free to subscribe for more but that will
do it for this week I've been totally
not mark thank you so much for watching
you